Call of Duty campaigns they're still a
thing and there are plenty of us fans
still out there 2019's Modern Warfare
saw Infinity Ward reboot their
much-loved Modern Warfare Trilogy with a
new gritty take on the genre well
grittier I guess than the last one
anyway the new campaign gave us an
action-packed Story full of
counter-terrorism Revenge and mustaches
gotta love that Tash
so if you're gearing up for Modern
Warfare 2's campaign get caught up on
the rebooted Modern Warfare story right
now the game kicks off in the fictional
region of verdansk where a CIA operative
known simply as Alex is raiding a
facility with a team of Marines to
search for a shipment of chemical gas
once the gas is located things go
sideways for the Americans very fast the
gas is stolen by a team of hostile
insurgents who kill everyone except for
Alex because that would be inconvenient
for the story at this point we jump to
another fictional country this time
urzakstan where a good deal of the
action takes place here we meet Alex's
CIA Handler station Chief Laswell who
has a big old chemical mess on her hands
to clean it up she calls in a favor from
everyone's favorite SAS mustache Captain
John Price ah it's good to have you back
Captain Flash Forward 24 hours and we're
in Merry Old London which has seen
better days the boots on the ground for
this mission is Sergeant Kyle Garrick
who's been investigating a group of
suspected terrorists who are thought to
be affiliated with an organization
calling themselves alcatala they
intercept a white van full of terrorists
and all hell breaks loose Garrick and
his team fight across the streets of
Piccadilly thwarting terrorists left
right and Center until our good mate
Captain Price turns up to help with
price on them for the ride the crisis is
somewhat averted but Piccadilly is left
looking like a war zone and that's
saying something if you've seen the
place at 1am on a Sunday morning
meanwhile Alex has been dispatched to
urzakstan to Rendezvous with an old
contact of prices the leader of the
local resistance Farah Karim Alex and
Farah strike a mutually beneficial deal
she'll Aid his search for the stolen
chemicals while he'll help in her
resistance against Russian occupiers led
by General Roman barkov Alex keeps his
end of the bargain by blowing up a pair
of helicopters and taking part in a huge
counter-offensive against barkov's men
aiding Farrah and her bigger brother
hadir as they take revenge on the regime
that have pressed their country back in
Bonnie old London Garrick's Intel on
alcatala has come good and revealed the
location of the terrorist safe house and
in the preceding mission one that was
analyzed by an sas Soldier on this very
Channel no less if you want to check
that out Garrick and price leader raid
on the property eventually learning the
location of alcatala's head honcho oh
man Suleiman AKA The Wolf all of which
leads us back to erzekstan where Alex is
roped into the mission to take the wolf
at his Hospital base which he does job
done only it's not job done as the
wolf's right hand man the butcher
because all these bad guys have to have
hard sounding names launches an attack
on the U.S embassy in a bid to take the
wolf back which he does all this despite
Captain Price and Sergeant Garrick
dropping in on the party to offer their
support so all in all the wolf was in
custody for what an hour that's all
semantics though as Farah has a plan to
hit back at the wolf and his forces on
the so-called highway of death from a
Hilltop sniper Den Alex Farah and Hader
complete with his highly improbable
homemade sniper rifle check out our
resident Firearms expert's opinion on
that one take the attack to a convoy of
alcatala forces the plan backfires when
barkov's men start shooting anyone in
sight and this mad cocktail of death
ends with the Revelation that Hader is
the thief responsible for stealing the
chemical gas supply a revelation that he
announces by triggering the gas and
killing everyone within range Farah and
Alex barely survive with their lives but
the gas offers some gnarly side effects
Chief among them a flashback yeah it's
20 years earlier and we're back to good
old 1999. here we witnessed the birth of
pharah's resistance which stems from a
particularly brutal encounter during
barcos initial invasion of urzakstan in
the ensuing chaos pharah witnesses her
father being murdered and her
neighborhood getting gaster within an
inch of its life Young pharah and Hades
survived the onslaught and make it out
of the deadly gas only to be caught by
barkov and his men at the very last
minute back in the present day and with
Hader seemingly in League with alcatala
pharah price Alex and Garrick all spring
a mission to infiltrate the wolf's
secret Den storming his base Our Heroes
locate the wolf and execute him but
Haider is nowhere to be seen and with a
good whack and the chemical gas still
unaccounted for the U.S government sever
any and all ties with pharah and her
resistance this naturally angers price
and Alex who agrees to stay in
Kazakhstan and fight alongside Farah not
sure the CIA are going to like that Alex
but who am I to say before this
bombastic story reaches its conclusion
though we've got one more flashback to
relive the year is 2009 and instead of
playing Modern Warfare 2 on our Xbox 360
pharah is still imprisoned by Barca but
not for long with the aid of a young
mustacheless price I mean what is this
fresh face it just doesn't look right
Farah and Hayden finally managed to
escape along with healthy dose of their
compatriots back to the present day
again and we're in Saint Petersburg
where price and Garrick are following up
on Intel that heyda is planning a
revenge-based attack in the city the
London Lads track down and intercept
alcatala before chasing the butcher
across town finally apprehending him and
with the butcher refusing to talk price
takes the gloves off and uses a pretty
dirty tactic forcing the butcher to talk
by threatening his family old Butch
finally spills the beans revealing that
Haider is planning an attack on barkov's
estate in Moldova and so price and
Garrick jump in a cop car and hightail
it down there when they get there the
whole place is crawling with guards
which is just a trivial matter at this
stage in COD campaigns Garrick and price
track down hey there to the third floor
of barkov's mansion and escort him off
the premises thanks to the untimely
arrival of barkov's goons though they
only just make it out by the Skin of
Their Teeth Haider trades his life for
Intel on barkov's gas facility but he's
thrown over to the Russians as soon as
the trio make contact with Laswell who
wants absolutely nothing to do with him
and with Hader out to their hair and the
Newfound knowledge of barkov's base of
operations price and Garrick re-team up
with Farah and Alex and this estranged
family all go on a Merry Old Crusade
into Georgia to take down barkov the
quartet split up once they reached the
facility with price and Garrick leading
the assault to plant the explosive
charges while pharah and Alex head to
intercept barkov himself in the ensuing
fight Alex is detonated for the charges
malfunctions and he opts to stay behind
to make sure the explosives go off in an
act of self-sacrifice which allows
pharah to take her revenge and barkov
and lead her people into the future and
take her revenge she undeniably does by
stowing away on barkov's personal
Chopper she sneaks up on the rotten
warlord and puts a knife in his back and
his chest and his neck and his yeah you
get the picture with price Garrick and
pharah at a safe distance the facility
blows Sky High bringing an end to
barkov's reign of terror but before the
credits roll we get a cheeky little
sequence between Laswell and price over
a nice cup property and God damn that
China looks fancy where'd you get that
that's besides the point the actual
point of this scene is to re-establish
our favorite Squad 141 from the original
Modern Warfare Trilogy with the reveal
that Garrick actually goes by the name
of Gaz alongside teases a fan favorites
John Soap MacTavish and Simon ghost
Riley all of which will no doubt feature
heavily in the campaign for Modern
Warfare 2. with the credits on the
campaign behind you the game kindly
tells you that the story continues in
Spec Ops and even offers up a handy
cinematic to set the scene with the wolf
dead alcatala is momentarily weak but
naturally a new leader sweeps into
Hoover up that power vacuum the US and
the Russians sync up to take down this
new threat under a joint organization
known as the Armistice and across a host
of Co-op missions set in verdansk they
Edge closer to the knowledge of who
they're dealing with turns out this new
big bad is a lad named Khalid al-assad
who's in League with an arms dealer
known as Victor zakayev but this is only
the tip of the iceberg lapping beneath
those icy waves are six whole seasons of
story content in the ever-expanding
Warzone mode while Warzone is largely a
huge multiplayer campaign it does offer
up a fair few story Revelations that
will naturally have a big impact on The
Narrative of Modern Warfare 2. The
Fragile alliance between the US and the
Russians starts to fracture as zakayev
and alcatala turn up the heat in
verdansk but don't you worry because
it's only bloody ghost to the rescue
making his first reappearance in this
rebooted franchise he contacts price to
send in reinforcements that they can
actually trust and lo and behold look
who's back from the dead it's our old
mate Alex who's still standing price and
gas themselves also end up heading to
verdansk to bring down zakayev but
they're also joined by a private
military outfit known as The Shadow
company who sinned in their own team led
by this big lad called Marcus Lurch
Ortega with the help of pharah and
Nikolai price and Co eventually track
zakayev to a nuclear Silo where he's
finally killed before price disengages a
world-ending missile from launching all
in a day's work a price and Warzone raps
a up its Modern Warfare storyline with
soap requesting backup and with our
Squadron of badasses wing suiting to his
Aid and that should have you all caught
up for Modern Warfare 2. thanks a lot
for watching this story recap I hope you
enjoyed it and I'll catch you guys next
time